[Music]
welcome
everybody to the h3 podcast
experience so great to have you with us
and
great to see you ila you look really
beautiful today with your orange
great idea i switched like three beanies
until i
decided on the orange the orange looks
great and i want to thank our sponsors
today stitch fix
ring seat geek and quidd today we've got
a whole slew of juicy topics to get to
including greg paul the father of jake
and logan paul
has not only made a tape in which he is
having
how do i say this without getting in
trouble with youtube where
uh he's uh his genitals is going into a
female genitals
people have speculated that this tape
that it records his genitals going into
another person's genitals
sex tape you could say sex tape yeah sex
tape
right that's the i don't know um
he said people are speculating it's an
underage girl
there's no evidence of that at all why
is it still called a tape
it's not really a tape is it we need to
update that
yeah sex footage vid tape sounds a
little more like
hidden away though it's like oh i got
that tape in my closet but really it's
just
on your phone yeah so it's not that fun
anymore but sex tape it still is sex
debut uh post malone has apparently been
cursed i love this story that's great
and of course the hilarious hilarious
antics of reporters from the recent
hurricane
there's a new trend and not really a
neutron they've been doing it for ages
where they just stand
in hurricanes and it's hilarious
and i've put together a whole thing so
these are this this and so much more
welcome everybody to the h3 bug guest
beyond the experience
fully enlightened i am your host ethan
klein with the beautiful
talented lovely incredible loving
elo client thank you love of my life
beautiful wow so great to have you
well enough about uh ela let's get to
the
one person in the world who turns me on
even more
greg paul
now
okay so let's start from the top because
this is a whole story that's kind of
developed so
i want to explain to you guys from the
top what happened
okay now first of all i think the first
thing that happened and dan correct me
if i'm wrong on anything but i think
i've got my facts straight
is that logan paul's channel was hacked
and the attacker uh
uploaded a basically a fake
iphone giveaway which is honestly not
that much of a departure from his usual
content
so i'm surprised anyone even noticed
because they took it down really fast
click the link in the description to
claim your free iphone x giving away
1500 iphones apparently people were
clicking this link and just getting like
straight up key loggers and
viruses which is great you know all the
best stuff on the internet has to offer
so that got taken down pretty quickly
and um
on sunday the hackers released jake
paul's
calendar via their twitter page which
has since been banned
it included the address and contact info
for many celebrities including justin
bieber yikes
and what was thought this is a great
twist thought to be ethan
me of course that's me um when jake paul
was on our podcast
he saved dan's number because he had a
pre-show call with dan
yeah and he saved it as h3h3
so dan's phone number was leaked
over uh blowing up with phone calls yeah
that was fun
tell me about that dan um yeah it was uh
what
sunday afternoon um was just chilling at
home and all of a sudden get a call from
an unknown number oh that's
weird no i ignored it what kind of
maniac
answers unknown numbers in 2018 yeah
that's just
crazy absolutely um but as soon as it
ended uh another one and then another
one another one and
pretty quickly i was like okay something
something happened this is
this is not normal and uh yeah just
tracked it down and see the old jakey
poo
did you not answer one of the calls no
no
did you get any texts or anything yeah
text well again because they thought it
was you
so it's just all kinds of people saying
what's up ethan and like
what kinds of messages for you so
anything uh interesting
no no really nothing interesting at all
yeah
i mean these people it's like you get a
hold of a number of a famous person
they have no idea what to say yeah
they're just calling a call you know
i'll say
when my phone number got leaked
previously when we got hacked dealer
and they posted our phone number on
twitter and we were
we were pro i swear to god we're getting
like 100 calls a minute
our phone was actually it i can't i
couldn't access my phone because there
was just incoming calls non-stop so i
didn't like swipe it open yeah i
couldn't even do anything
but i was getting tons of text messages
and i don't think i actually ever
told you this but somebody sent me i
don't know why i even opened text
message because i was generally not
but one of them was a dick pic and i
have to tell you
really i did feel violated and in that
moment i had
a i had a moment of like empathy and
sympathy
for all the females out there getting
unsolicited dick pics because it felt
it felt very vi i felt very violated
that i saw this
man he was a fat man with a tiny small
penis it looked almost like my own if
i'm being honest a tiny little penis the
pubes were much longer than the penis
itself
and i was like whoa is that a picture i
took no it was someone sending me
their own so um
you think it was his picture and not
something off the internet no it was
definitely dude just snapped his junk
and
sent it to me yeah so there's a fat
chubby little penis so you were me too
i was me too i've i've been trying to
tell you that for a long time
trying to take back me too for us for me
meet anyway so apparently me third
apparently the hacker this this kind of
perplexes me this hacker got into jake
logan and their father's account all
three like
i mean these guys are big shots
they have run big companies how first of
all is their security
not tighter run third of all how do you
get into all three of them
at the same time what i was wondering is
are they still all on the same family
plan at verizon or some [ __ ]
you know what i mean like how do you
explain that they got all three of their
accounts yeah i don't know
fascinating stuff well regardless of how
it happened
um it could only happen to these
geniuses
um apparently so in jake's
dm's there's all kinds of uh stuff of
him flirting with girls
i don't know apparently they they teased
all kinds of stuff but they didn't show
anything so i don't know but definitely
the most [ __ ] up thing to come out of
it by far was um
the greg paul sex tape greg paul being
the father um
this guy is a piece of work man greg
paul is the guy who has
notoriously made out with little girls
in one of jake's videos
kissed kissed i mean there might have
been sorrows
and he seems he wears a p he's a he's 40
how old is he down he's like 45
54. yeah i think that's right i mean
here here's all you need to know about
the guy he's a 54 year old man with a
puka shell necklace and a goatee
i mean rules hit me with some of those
sound bites would you zack
gp coming at you gp is coming at you
that's his interests
he talks he like lowers his voice and
talks like uh it's like he's doing
anything
imitation of his sons yeah yeah
hey yo it's jp coming at you yo
what's going on
it sounds like he's auditioning for the
new blues clues opening
um anyway so so there was a sex
tape but there's no faces
there's some voices obviously the girl
herself there's no way of knowing
her age or identity which is good for
her thank god for that i mean
it's so graphic you guys i've watched a
lot of porn in my day a lot of porn
let me emphasize a lot of porn in my day
this is one of the most graphic things
i've ever seen in my life i mean it is
horrif i mean it was horrifying it's
really horrific
let me play you a little sound bite the
lovely thing was that it was just on
twitter and like
i just saw people talk about it
and going up the thread of a
conversation it's just there on twitter
yeah that's how i saw it first too
but i saw what i saw was like
him like fingering her but then i
doing my research i watched the whole
thing on one of these
uh you know websites
and it is so graphic bro there's one
scene where he's slapping her with his
ding i'm i'm gonna use i'm gonna use pc
words here because we
are family friendly show he uses his uh
carrot he he puts his carrot in her soil
but what happens is he's slapping her
slapping her peach with his carrot and
she starts to
water his carrot he she pees on his dick
i swear to god she pees on his dick and
this is the sound
that it makes this is the sound from the
video she pees on his dick i swear to
god
so he's slapping her and she's peeing on
his dick
do you think asmr people would love this
sound greg paul sex stick asmr that's
interesting let me try to experience
stuff that stays smart
i'm definitely getting the time i'm
feeling a tingle in my forehead
so this video is so
graphic um but again there's no
there's nothing identifying the man or
or the female
yeah so my first thought was like okay
this could be anyone let's let first of
all i want to see is this actually
greg paul not that i'm not willing to
believe it
i mean i'm very willing to believe it
but i just want to know
what's my hunch so here we've got some
evidence here
um let me see here
um you ready to come again
definitely sounds like hit me with the
hit me with that
coming at you you ready to come again
could be
what's going on people coming at you
well here we do a little csi photo
matching
and this is fairly conclusive in my
opinion
um here it's hard to tell okay but like
here's uh from his instagram his dog
sleeping on his bed
now what we're paying our attention to
is this floral
kind of pattern here in the woodwork and
you can tell
i know it's i know this doesn't look
that good okay it does not
but i'm telling you i've watched the
videos there's better screenshots
but it definitely it matches it's the
same headboard when
when it's in motion in the video yeah
it's a lot more evident that it's the
same thing
it's definitely the same so what do you
think is happening
but um i thought i had more evidence
than that
well let's leave that that's all the
evidence i've got
it's okay let me say this it's
definitely the same headboard
in your opinion and my humble alleged
opinion
it's not even an opinion it's an alleged
opinion
is that your opinion sir allegedly
um is she under age though i mean
who could ever say that that's dangerous
yeah i don't i don't want to
put out the guys having sex with
underage girls i would believe him he
was having
would i would it be a stretch of my
imagination
to think that greg was having sex with
energy girls no absolutely not videos of
him kissing
absolutely not um
but what about what
yeah the first thought i had was like
that's not you can't really use that as
evidence in court because it's illegally
obtained
yeah well regardless there's no evidence
this girl's underage at all so
um i don't want to insinuate that now
basically though greg
has acknowledged that the hack has
happened in this instagram video which i
will
play for you all here today
just a little something to tell you over
as i open this
by the way greg is a high level
instagram
user he starts the video with he got a
paper bag from like ralph's
supermarket and he just sharpied a
message so that this would be the
thumbnail
it's very creative i'm telling you he's
high level dude
he learned it from all the teenage girls
he [ __ ] allegedly
allegedly i don't even have an opinion i
have an alleged opinion
uh my hacker thought my hacker taught me
a lot
please contact me so i can hire you
bro you couldn't find a piece of paper
you really had to use a ralph's shopping
bag
all right let's watch this enjoy this
yo yo
she be here gp coming at you
you ready to come again you ready to
come again you ready to come again guys
gp coming at you all right so a lot of
you guys know that i was hacked by the
way this hacker dude is something else
man he is crazy smart
i learned a lot he sounds like such a
[ __ ] he sounds like he's 15 why does
he talk like that
he reminds me of the guy isn't there
character in like fast finds at
ridgemont high played by matthew
mcconnery
mcconaughey he's like a 30 year old that
hangs around
that's confused yeah what what is what's
that great line
he he has all right all right all right
oh there he is
had it ready to go he has a line he goes
i get older but they stay the same age
something that's what he loves about
high school girls is the line so he
pretty much is that character and really
from him um
you know hacking is actually an adult
way of bullying
what do you think about that i thought
that was kind of interesting hacking is
actually an adult way of bullying
is this him saying he thinks he's been
bullied right now
we need to call uh trump's wife see
where he's coming from
with that statement really it is a
little bit but
okay what do you think i don't know you
thought it was funny thing
he's being bullied poor guy and uh
you know i don't know why the guy does
it because he doesn't get any
real recognition for it uh he's not
really messing up my life that bad
because my life
my i'm just not that important but um
i learned a lot from him i learned about
some ways to prevent hacking and all
this stuff but dude if you're out there
i want you to reach out to me the guy
still has my aol
it makes it sound like his password was
like password
i learned a lot about security
greg paul rules he still has his aol
account oh i missed that
wait i can't remind you give back my aol
account including your information there
because i want to hire you
of course craig paul uses aol he wants
to hire the hacker
how about thrown into jail i think this
was probably an elaborate ruse too
to get them this was his mastermind
but you know greg paul probably still
has aol dial-up
on autopay you know what i mean i read i
read a stat that there's like a million
people still paying aol
on a dial-up like all these old people
that never upgraded their internet
they're all
like i bet you my grandparents he's like
94
still pays aol for dial up
we can use your smarts in in your skill
set in a positive way and probably make
you a [ __ ] ton of legit money
anyway i hope you guys have a great
weekend i hope you guys have a great day
and check these out
those were the two fingers gross i'm
just
telling you honestly he did this and boy
i saw those fingers
and a bucket of piss it goes
you ready to come again anyway i feel
bad for him hacking's no fun it is adult
bowling you're right
i feel bad in a way i hope that girl
wasn't underage all those hackers
just say such a nice adult bullying
oh so now you agree i agree i came
before i came around
it's adult bowling it's it is i don't
know it's it sucks it's the worst thing
to go through and it's like
yeah it's awful anyway my heart goes out
to greg paul
and um it gushes for him you might say
my heart gushes for him
one might say that and um i really hope
the girl was not under age
for for his sake for all of our sick for
the world's sake
please greg don't be [ __ ] underage
girls and recording it
because like we're the world is just not
ready for that
the polls aren't ready for that youtube
is not ready for that
greg please my heart gushes for you
though
you ready to come again all right
all right so we can wrap it up from here
apparently the hacker said um
what is this the hacker said that they
have
way more effed up evidence that they've
forwarded to the fbi but yeah who knows
why well all of a sudden they have a
conscience you know
so there you go um
greg i mean greg is smashing though
he came out here he's jake's manager
he's
apparently yes since nick crompton left
greg has
taken over the mantle and he is smashing
dude
you need me to play that again no okay
uh moving on post malone is cursed
you guys you may have heard the recent
reports that first of all you all heard
about how his plane took off
and the wheel blew up on takeoff they
had emergency land
thank god post malone was okay next up
the next couple of days he's in a car
crash with someone driving a quarter
million rolls royce a car crash thank
god he's okay god bless the sweetheart
of that man
and then an armed robbery took place at
his old house that place we've been to
i if it's the place i'm thinking of
which i think it has to be
we've been there a lot of times that's
scary armed
robbers show up at the house asking
where post malone
is terrifying and i'm so glad that post
wasn't there he had since
moved and the tenants that were living
there
got stood up at uh gunpoint they stole
like 20 000 worth of something
jewelry so i'm
i'm i'm so glad that austin wasn't there
because he's a kind of
we don't call 911 kind of guy you know
what i mean
that would have been some some gunfire
i have a bad feeling but anyway what is
going on with post malone
well we think we have the answer guys we
think we figured it out
and of course it's tmz who has put the
pieces
together um post mom messing with evil
spirits on video now cursed plane and
car makes sense
it all makes sense finally
this guy zach from ghost hunting these
guys are so funny
you know how i feel about ghost hunting
postmodern loves it though
so apparently um
there's this uh zach tells us the close
encounter went down in june and his
haunted
museum the object is called the
book box debug is yiddish for malicious
spirit and the box inspired the horror
flick position really yiddish
so they're saying the jews are behind
all of it
great it's another jewish conspiracy
so wait explain what is this so this box
this guy zach the ghost hunter it's
apparently the most cursed
item in the world because they're jewish
ghosts and they got it right they have a
chip on their shoulder yeah there's
videos so this is it
dude you got oh [ __ ] let me put what the
[ __ ]
dude you got that's kind of dope think
about that it's like um
of all the cursed objects in the world
you got cursed gypsy [ __ ]
cursed polish [ __ ] cursed whatever
german [ __ ]
yeah it's the yiddish ghosts that are
the most gnarly
the jewish ghosts are the ones you
absolutely do not want to [ __ ] with
it's kind of dope so here's the video
that explains everything that's been
going on
i want you guys to so that's uh at his
house or something it's at his haunted
museum in
i think vegas so this is the first time
he's actually
apparently taken the box off or touched
the case itself
that's the story so postman is freaking
out he's like don't do it but that's
where postman [ __ ] up you see
see zach the ghost hunter knows what
he's doing he knows how to handle the
curse
he touched the box the first one ever to
do it post him alone being the sweet guy
he tried to break him away from the box
but curse was transferred to him in that
[Laughter]
moment
the lights are off obviously first add
spooky effect
they're like you know we could have the
lights on
but let's leave them off um this is the
cursed jew room what's with the star of
david's in like you've got like a
torah and [ __ ] what is this some kind of
[ __ ] jewish fun house
austin's freaked the [ __ ] out he's
trying to get out oh he turned on the
lights thank god austin
oh he did yeah he just turned on the
lights here you can see i'll go back
he goes back to the door he's like [ __ ]
this turns on the lights
oh zach is trying to play it cool like
he doesn't care
um but here he goes in austin's like
dude
this is it this isn't just any ghost
this is a yiddish ghost because austin
knows better
you know we went when we went go
something with austin he was very
respectful he was very cautious about
the spirits he really
he believes this stuff yeah and he was
not [ __ ] around so i
know that he's he's deadly serious about
this stuff no there was that thing where
when he ho when he opens the door i
think there's like something
moving out of the room we'll have to do
a play-by-play but first
let's hone in on that but first let's
see what happens
so austin is freaking out he's got a
beer in hand he's trying to talk
zach into getting out he's hyper vetting
he's breathing heavy he's grabbing him
he's saying they run out of the room
now
post malone being the sweet guy he was
he took the curse from zach and these
old yiddish girls you know what i need
to do i think i can
resolve this what because these yiddish
ghosts they need a good jewish boy
to come talk sensitive
i think i can channel maybe these
yiddish ghosts and and
they're gonna catch the curse no no no i
am a good jewish boy
i'm well fed that is all a yiddish
grandmother ever wanted
i'm a good sweet bar mitzvah and i think
that i can talk some sense into these
yiddish ghosts
should i say a prayer no
i think i should say a prayer to lift
the curse
uh can you pipe me in some uh prayer uh
prayer
spooky yiddish prayer music
[Laughter]
um this is maybe appropriate no no this
is too sad isn't it
um angelic music there's no there's
angels in judaism right
no no no no no no no no for christ's
sake curse on you yiddish curse on you
all right uh yiddish spirits
what was what were they called they were
called the um
d-book spirits cursing post malone
he's a good boy he's a
good sweet boy he loves his parents
and is this the prayer yeah
this is my prayer i'm trying to banish
the trying to banish the yiddish
ghost he eats well
and i've cooked latkes with for him on
several occasions
we spend dreidel on hanukkah together
me and austin have spun dreidel and you
are going to curse this good jewish boy
how dare you
austin comes from a good family
and was and also he loves holo bread
i know that because i've shared holo
bread with him
if you can lift this curse yiddish
spirits diblik
what is it
and return to your box
then this jewish boy will be forever
grateful that i'm a bar mitzvah oh man
this is so funny there's a bunch of like
uh
d book boxes on ebay really
and they all look so weird this is one
let
he was on the [ __ ] search for some
debut
get some d book up in here let's order
one oh we can buy this [ __ ] on
well what's so special we could buy this
[ __ ] on ebay something
you're so kid made haunted d book box 20
bucks
really
i feel like i'm getting cursed just
looking at it
what is going on with that heart
wrenching i'm [ __ ]
um there's more in the related items
like
what is this can you play play me music
play me any music cause i seriously want
to get rid of this curse and i care a
lot
about post malone got a chip on your
shoulder get some therapy
in the afterlife there's somebody out
there that can help you
for christ's sake don't take your
disappointment and your grandchildren
out on post malone all jewish grand
parents are disappointed in their
grandchildren that's life
be at peace david beautiful i think uh
folks would appreciate that really
powerful stuff do i you think i think i
left the curse i felt there was a change
in the uh
felt that there was a change
the spirit meanwhile i don't know i felt
like maybe
austin probably i think he owes me
um can we uh show them though
noticed this very spooky moment here i
write it in the comments but
so go ahead when he opens the door
was it there watch the top right
right where he opens the door at the top
there it goes
there's something that flies out of the
room left side right here you see where
my mouse is
it flies all the way from here out the
door yeah watch this
when he opens the door you see that did
you see that
i said said i'm telling you it was
spookfest 2000 and [ __ ] 18.
here right here off one more time watch
it comes from the left side of screen
out the door there it goes a white light
now a reasonable exponent could be a bug
bug it could be the reflection on the
door reflecting off the camera or
something like that you know what i mean
but most likely it's a debug that came
and infected the whole [ __ ] planet
do i need to say another blessing i
don't think we've had enough everyone's
like
[ __ ] no all right
well anyway my first thought was like
seriously the jews are behind this
yeah blame the jews typical i can
believe this
items which is found on ebay all right
well
x up next we've got the nutty
weather reporters all their coverage of
this hurricane was
outlandish and insane and hilarious so
stay tuned we will be right back after
this
short words from our sponsors through my
mouth
stitch fix has reimagined the way we
find and buy clothing here's what stitch
fix is
you go to their website you fill out a
questionnaire
you tell them what your budget what kind
of guy are you
and a stylist springs into actual your
virtual mom or girlfriend
does a little shopping for you and sends
it to you okay
now that's convenient enough as it is
but here's the thing
if you don't like it you don't keep it
if it doesn't fit you don't
keep it you send it back boom it's so
convenient
that's it you know some guys can't dress
and let's face it one of those guys is
dan our producer
he's a sweet guy but he started using
stitch fix unlike me
i'm mr suave i always dress great psych
that's ela that drift
dan on the other hand i always dress
like an idiot what am i even saying
dan on the other hand loves stitch fix
he uses it all the time and he can't put
this hoodie down
dan tell them about how much you love
stitch fix
it's just unbelievable it's changed my
whole life
i sense a little irony there dan but i
know that you're not being ironic you're
being genuine because it's a great
service
i recommend everybody try the stylus fee
is only 20 which is applied as a credit
towards anything you keep so guys hurry
to stitchfix.com
h3 and get started right freaking now
because if you keep all five items in
your box you get 25
off your purchase go to stitchfix.com
h3 ring's mission is to make
neighborhoods safer i love ring i've
been using this product
for years and for me it's changing the
way
that home security works you got a ring
what it first of all it started with the
doorbell
you click the doorbell it makes a noise
inside like a normal doorbell but it's
also got a camera and a microphone
so if somebody's peeping creeping on
your door stealing a package whatever
bs shenanigans they're up to not only
does it record them
based on motion but it zaps the
recording up to the cloud
and saves it forever that means that
they're
not getting away and you can talk to
them you can tell them
hey buddy watch out f exactly you
and now we're talking home security now
here let me tell you about
they've got ring flood lights these
things are awesome i got them stalled in
our house it's so great
it's a flood light and motion detector
and a video camera offers the same thing
you could blossom with the siren too
it's incredible and they've got this
thing on the app called neighbors
and like all your neighbors within like
a two or three mile radius upload videos
of shenanigans going on at their house
it's like a little community and it's so
great like there's these old ladies that
post videos of like delivery guys that
are going to the wrong door
they're like this guy was ringing at my
door at 8 00 p.m does anyone know who
i'm
and everyone's clowning on the old lady
like it's a delivery it's a delivery
like
really is this what this apps come to
it's hilarious but there's some good
stuff there too but it's
there's a lot of entertainment and
besides the entertainment it's great
security guys i cannot endorse this
product
enough as a listener you've got a
special offer on a rink starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell
motion activated floodlight cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
build a ring security around your home
so go to ring.com h3 that's ring.com
h3 i love this product i use it
personally
i endorse it you pick this up you're
gonna love it
ring.com h3
see geek you know them you love them you
need tickets to a place
do it with sea geek it's easy as that
you're going to see a sporting event
sikhi you're going to see a music
concert siki are you going to watch
jake paul live in concert and want front
row seats
so you can get squirted on by his dad
seeky
guys they've got you covered on
everything
okay now um there here's what's great
one to ten score look at the seat
they'll tell you straight up
no bs one to ten if it's a good score
green is good
red is bad i mean it's basically
you see the view from the seat boom
there's no surprises
it's just a good reliable place to get
tickets
up front honest here's the best part
and i got to tell you there's no kicker
here we got a hookup for all you guys
use code h3h3
for 20 bucks off your first order just
click the me tab on the app and enter
code
h3h3 for 20 off guys it's not
this is them just handing you 20 bucks
to go see
a live show it doesn't get better than
that and frankly you might even catch a
little bit of uh
greg paul's fluid on your face
so i say that's a bye and not take me
with and
for two please uh check the link in the
description to download the app remember
guys use code h3h3
for 20 off your first seat geek order
it's honest
it's great it's straightforward you need
tickets see geek's got you covered
quid is a totally free app for ios and
android you can collect stickers gifts
cards 3d toys for free
all on your phone stickers from shows
like rick and morty bob's burgers games
of thrones
disney marvel naruto oh [ __ ] naruto
how do you say naruto i always say it
wrong what's the weeb away
naruto naruto i don't know even our
buddy jack film yes that's right where
the f
f is my stickers jack film has stickers
i don't have stickers
plus they're updating adding new stuff
all the time you can then trade them
with your friends or even text them in
imessage by dragging and dropping them
into your messages
there are a ton of shows and influencers
in there now remember
it's totally free some of the packs and
box opening are super rare and you can
meet other fans of quid and trade with
them to complete your favorite sets
try your best rank on the leaderboard
for every given set
as you can see here it's all playing out
before our eyes
it's all free guys the items it's all
free the app is free
you get more coins every few hours and
if you want more
you just watch and add or you pay to get
a couple more coins so you can get some
more stickers
so follow the link in the description of
this episode to download the app from
either the apple or
android store and start collecting your
favorite stickers today
thank you to quid get trading boys
welcome back nutty
weather reporters this has been a
phenomenon that's been going on
um these reporters they send them out
into hurricanes in treacherous weather
crap crack open here as sody pump
and they make these poor sons of [ __ ]
basically
brave dangerous winds
and sometimes the winds they're not that
dangerous and so they have to hype up
the danger themselves
we've got a little of each got a little
all of it
what was the name of this recent
hurricane florence
that's right so uh you guys may have
heard there was one particular gentleman
um that was called out all over the
internet for his
uh hurricane florence meme and this guy
was out in the weather channel and it's
kind of this classic story
of acting like the weather is insane and
then somebody walking
through the back well here i'll i'll let
you watch
all right give me a break
now first of all worth noting is um
he's leaning and wilmington north
carolina right at the end of the coast
away from the where the wind is flying
like that doesn't make any sense
people have said that maybe he's
covering the microphone but that doesn't
really make sense to me
because you can see as it goes on he's
clearly not covering the microphone he's
just
just whipping through here more heavy
rain
he's trying to brace himself now that is
a pretty healthy gust right there
but anyway here in the beginning you can
see a couple of dudes just strolling as
casual as possible
okay here you go and wilmington north
carolina right at the intracoastal
and we're in one of these bands this is
these guys are just
literally strolling by as casually as
there's truly no problem balancing
gusting again over 60 miles an hour
yeah so there you go who would have
thought
people got really excited only on
youtube i thought people exaggerate and
clickbait you know it's funny and these
are like real professional weathermen
these are like scientists that's what
i'm saying you set up these atmospheres
and everybody
will be reduced to uh click baiting
nice asmr spaghetti sound
oh jesus christ i click and it starts
again so anyway
people got really upset by this um
over dramatizing of how bad it is i find
it just funny it's like damn
you're out there bracing yourself the
wrong way
you know anyway
the other excuse i heard is there
anything to this that it's that
oh well he was um he was standing on
grass is why
yeah i've got that from the i'll read
that what does that mean
well i have a statement from the weather
report they defend him
against the claims and i've i've got it
all laid out
i want to enjoy some more footage of
this guy bracing against the treacherous
weather
and we're getting gusts uh pushing that
still
so you know it goes without saying the
categories
sometimes are misleading with hurricanes
or the wind just
whipping through here more heavy gusts
48 miles per hour
hold on there bye hold on there give me
a break yeah
where's that you have to lower your
center hold on there buddy
he's like on top of a bronco or some
[ __ ] anyway
so we've got a whole thing here let's
see what we got so this guy got into a
bunch of
of uh stuff and weather's channel
made a statement they're supporting
their boy they're not leaving them out
in the trenches they that's
good yeah and they got his back you know
whether people the weather people they
they're tight-knit community they said
it's important to note that the two
individuals in the background are
walking on concrete
and mike sedel they name him they name
him and shame him
first and last name and mike settle is
trying to maintain his footing on wet
grass
after reporting on air until 1am this
morning and is undoubtedly exhausted
well i mean my counter is just stand on
the concrete
how are you standing on grass changes
anything
it doesn't i haven't noticed it doesn't
when i stand on grass
it doesn't really that much they those
yeah i don't know
it doesn't really um but the weather
the weather channel they love this
hurricane [ __ ]
they go crazy this they they blew their
entire production budget
for the whole year they put together
these insane
3d renders where these reporters stand
in like a sphere with a massive crazy
green screen
and they show you virtually like where
the water heights
are will be and it's just so over the
[ __ ] top for what i
it's amazing it's really cool but
they're also just so
jacked about these her hurricanes and
here let me show you
it's kind of crazy look at this [ __ ]
that
certainly is enough to knock you off
your feet it could definitely stall cars
out
and even carry cars away and certainly
flood many of the lower levels of
structures
but we know florence is also going to
bring water
so the water yeah now six feet of water
imagine that
imagine that i don't need to imagine
anymore
for example the technology of the
weather man
don't tell me it goes higher where else
can we use this
no it goes technology higher you said it
perfectly it reminds me of
like uh just the sucker the ducker
cruise through puerto rico
the puerto rico live stream there are
fish in the water
why the [ __ ] is there fish in the world
it's just that realistic
one-story buildings and structures the
details matter you can
certainly pose a risk to many there are
very few places
so he would be dead now yeah it's like
down there
man he's underwater didn't even show
it's a garbage bag it's a corpse and a
vet
so you know the intention is good heed
the advice and get the hell out of there
don't get washed away
don't brave the storm you know it's
funny i find ironic all these weather
reporters are like do
not brave the storm everybody evacuate
and meanwhile i'm going to do it
get blown away and then listen to me
they try to justify staying because it's
so stupid by
over reacting and acting like
[ __ ] nothing's happening
there's another clip of a girl i love i
love these clips it's just
it's incredible i love their enthusiasm
for hurricanes
florence is a large and extremely
destructive hurricane
storm surge is going to be potentially
life-threatening for some areas
along the u.s coastline and already this
morning we've seen the water picking up
over some of the roadways
let's go ahead and take a look at what
could be a reasonable worst case
scenario for areas
along north carolina all the way here
from surf city to north topsail beach we
could be talking about up to six feet of
storms
and again impacts have already begun
today with the storm approaching
even inland it's not just going to be a
coastal event here areas along rivers
like
the map we can show you what this could
look like if you were to find yourself
in this scenario
once that water comes up to three feet
you can see my shins up towards my waist
this could be enough to knock you off
your feet the other guy had the same
exact speed that would be part of the
side of the roadway
this is extremely dangerous oh it's the
same exact footage six foot range
interesting how high this water goes
winds pick everything up see that little
move she did yeah
i thought that was great i love that
love it very much
and then of course there was of all
things like you said they probably blew
up all their
budget dude they have a production
budget that they blow
one week the next where the report is
gonna be on like the
cell phone camera yeah exactly they
don't they can't afford
cameraman anymore then of course there
was um
looting interestingly of all places
a dollar store was looted
if you're gonna i mean uh the dollar
store looters
that's good that could be a video game
dollar store looters
that's gotta be i mean that's rock
bottom i mean [ __ ] dilute somewhere else
at least if you're going to break the
law
get something more valuable than a
neiman marcus or something come on
yeah well anyway let's watch the video
this reporter is very brave
kitchen towels couple kitchen towels
some juice some
some cheap oil
that's useful uh you know you could get
there you could steal
a 10-pack of sporks what is pork
it's a it's a fork spoon combination
into one utensil
oh there's some fancy sporks that
actually have a knife on the side
that's outside of that's the two that's
you can't find that
kind of quality at the dollar store
though
um is anyone else upset that
at the dollar store or not everything
cost a dollar
shouldn't it be i think consistent you
know it doesn't upset me because i know
that you sometimes i would go shopping
in those stores and then it's
what i want is like 15. 15
that no that's too far yeah if you have
a 15
item in the dollar store close up i'm
looting
is what i'm gonna do i'm alluding your
dollar store i understand in this day
and ages 2018
we've had inflation if you you can kick
it up to two or three bucks for a really
premium i'm talking about
a spork with a knife up the side you can
charge your premium for that
no i remember even in israel we have
those stores and it's like a
second store that's 25 cents by the way
but then what i want would be 20 seconds
oh give me a [ __ ] break yeah
you make a scene do you do you throw
stuff do you
yell don't you no i just
just only buy the the sheker and stuff
okay what do you buy for a shekel that's
only 25 cents
i used to love buying stickers there
because they would have like
really weird chinese knockoff stickers
when like how much money weird looking
well that's what these people are
stealing because this is a dollar store
so
just find it interesting
i can't tell if i feel bad because it's
like pure desperation
they might need food i mean how
desperate are you if you're stealing
[ __ ] from a dollar store
i don't know situation go for it i say
really you say loot the dollar store
that's really illegal activity
well sure i i i feel bad i feel bad it's
an emergency someone owns that store
well
it's kind of drizzling dan i'm not going
to say that this is a life or death
situation is it on this particular clip
it's a little but you never know
but i'm saying like if you're if you're
if you're looting
a dollar store you're not like you know
set for life i mean you might be able to
enjoy those stickers i think
also if you own a dollar store you're
not set for life it depends is it a
chain is it mom and pop's dollar store
is it a dollar tree
dollar tree can get looted the [ __ ] out
of it yeah it's fine
yeah damn and when when did you become
such a vigilante
jesus christ hey man when it's an
emergency
background check on that i know i didn't
i just i just remember we never
did a background check on dan
dan's like a police murderer
anyway watch the bravery of this lady as
she confronts these awful dollar store
criminals in the wake of this awful
tragedy
it's a national emergency guys
hey guys you know i'm just i want to
identify what they're stealing so this
guy's got a 12 pack of coke zero by the
way cheers to him
excellent taste young man
that's actually those are mini cans it
looks like
maybe a six pack of mini how much would
that cost
at ralph's those run about three bucks
so three dollars but if it's a six pack
of mini cans you might be able to get
those for a buck
they're probably expired honestly
excuse me do you know that you're
stealing a six packs of uh coke zero
excuse me what does she think you're
caught
committing an act of crime you're
supposed to stop and do a little
interview
you know what i mean can we see your
face please sir and uh your name and
phone number and address
i'm really curious what both stealing
sir you know
wait the kid playing i'm just trying i
really
he's got what looks like a tub with like
maybe some detergent
a little tupperware i mean look if
you're willing to steal
detergent well anyway
stealing is stealing folks am i right
i'm just saying
you know that you're looting would i
break the law and compromise everything
i stand for as a human being to get a
free six-pack of coke zero expired
yes legal you can see people coming out
apple juice
with items left and right from the store
it's like when
you're in class and a couple kids are
cheating on the exam
she's like the kid that's like i see you
guys she's a little nervous she's a
[ __ ] snitch is what you mean
yeah i see nobody wanted they like
candles
there's a full shelf of like candles or
like something on there
[Music]
look at the store yeah that place is
trashed
she's so concerned let's see if we can
go back around front guys
she's brave there are no uh
she's truly brave law enforcement on
site
oh [ __ ] no law enforcement excuse me sir
um
what are you going to be doing with that
uh small
can of tomato paste talking to me all
right
look across the street here people uh
filling up what looks like laundry bags
full of items
wow running it's amazing excuse me sir
we're out here let's go back to the
front crystal uh excuse me sir
what are you trash bags you are stealing
a what are those toy guns with like
little cr anyway
this is uh this is what's the worst of
the worst in these hurricanes folks
toilet paper toilet paper is expensive
what did you say this is the worst of
the worst if this is as bad as it gets
i don't think so i think i'm losing your
house there's people that died
some some poor kids taking like a
six-pack of toilet paper that's just on
the ground this is as bad as it gets
folks
meanwhile people are [ __ ] dead their
house is floating down anyway it's all
funny it's all funny
i'm not saying looting i'm not defending
lewd in if the situation's hilarious
they're looting a dollar store you got
this reporter that thinks she's like on
the ground in vietnam or something
you know what i mean to the worst in
these hurricanes folks
uh people getting desperate looking for
items
looks like they've just busted
completely through the door here
i would watch i could i swear to god for
another 30 minutes
i love that clip
wonderful stuff really great stuff um
what else we got a
manner of time oh yeah so here's another
bozo out
in the storm from the hurricane now this
guy
on the opposite end you've got dude
pretending to be in danger
and then you've got dude because you
send these reporters out when sometimes
it is actually dangerous
and this is one of those times leslie
fill it back to you
ted before we let you go some of these
ted before we let you go we want to make
sure that
you die some of these different live
shots
we've seen we've seen people wandering
around a little bit
are those reporters out covering or are
you seeing
residents in the area just kind of
coming out and taking a look at things
this morning i i've seen a couple
reporters out driving around
but as we as we turn around now there
aren't many that we can see they're
starting to be a couple of the people
who have stuck around that gentleman
down there and a yellow raincoat is a
local
uh
he got slammed by a huge uh sheet metal
he's a little we're okay that was just
not cut
he's a little spooked
and i think he's ready to get out of
there yeah
i'm gonna let this go and i'm gonna let
you guys go all right ted
ted before you go uh can you tell us how
did that feel
getting hit by a sheet metal do you see
any other debris flying around
he pulled that on him uh ted before you
go
you're not getting paid extra hours yeah
i'm gonna head out of here i'm gonna let
you guys go uh ted before you go
can you tell me do you see corpses
around do you see any other flying
debris
by the way the one thing that's always
common in these reporters out on the
field they're getting blown away and
acting like the world's in chaos
the camera man is standing there holding
the super heavy thing he never [ __ ]
budges
you know that's true
ted before you go not all heroes were
reporter outfits right well said elon
give that a word out of work
before you go ted can you uh go near
any uh glass windows that are likely to
bust out
all right ted
oh looks like ted got hit by a sheet
metal
before you go ted
anyway good stuff huh
do we have quality content here or what
um
and then of course you got some classic
ones
that i wanted to share with you guys you
may have seen it but these are my
the favorite ones well i mean this guy
got in trouble but i feel like these
guys kind of goofed up even worse
because
well oh oh this lady's in a canoe okay
i love this guy next door he's just like
what the hell are we doing manchester
and there's someone walking by ankle
ankle high
really cut out quick but the next one's
as good as it gets here let's pull this
one up here
where did they get a canoe they brought
it flooding here in the northeast as
more rain continues to fall today
and sees michelle kozinski
she's in a canoe new jersey this morning
michelle good morning to you she's got a
paddle she's paddling her canoe
obviously we're getting a nice break
from the rain but not the flooding
and somebody literally walked two guys
who were like [ __ ] this lady
walk right in front of her and it's just
at ankle depth
and what i love about the reporters is
they call her out
it's so great they don't try to say well
she was standing on uh
she was standing grassy water there was
a there was a deep point
deep point pull a canoe or boat when
you're out in it
it's much deeper back there because this
is haiti actually michelle i'll take it
is there some kind of severe drop
off there uh between the floor
you guys when you have a ride like this
why would you want to walk
have you run ashore you know what's
funny they're pro all the producers are
probably in on it and they just
tossed her ass hard
by the way shout out to matt lauer who
actually had a button and his
this is matt lauer oh that's him yeah
the bathroom guy he had a button in his
office he got me too
his story is one of my favorites he he
didn't get he me
too he didn't get me to it right that's
the term
he got me tood he tuned he too
he did yeah he too
so he's one of my favorites he and
this is crazy he had a button installed
under his deck
so when people or female interns or
whatever
came into his office he had a button he
would push that
lock the [ __ ] door behind them
how do you even think about that that's
like dr evil [ __ ] yeah
a button that locks the door from the
outside
anyway good shout out to matt lauer
how did he even explain that when he was
like ordering it you know
like what do you put on the work order
just put it on that
weatherman budget they got all that
they're gonna have the
now what this button does is it locks
the door
from the outside so i can really focus
and get some work done
right now now it's for me to be able to
focus
but just hypothetically if somebody
wanted to get out they
have to push this button under my desk
to get out now that's just to make sure
that i can focus all the way that i need
to
michelle of course
i wonder if you ever push the button on
her you know what i mean shall we step
into my office
i'm waiting about there the button what
are you reading about it though
talk to me and it turns out it did not
install it it was a mechanism that was a
standard feature in many of the
older offices that was like the whole
story you're debunking that
yeah well what was the story what did he
get in trouble for then
well it's more about the i think he
didn't personally
yeah wait he raped somebody no i don't
know what he did
but sexual misconduct whatever there's
allegations but
people were wondering about that if he
installed it personally
okay so he didn't that's just a standard
issue for example
back in the 50s yeah that was the
standard
um okay now moving on
shout out to matt lauer
i hope he's doing good wherever he is
meme inception 90 day fiance we all know
and love this show very much i'm a huge
fan of this show
saw this on the subreddit there was a
trailer for season six i have to tell
you
90 day fiance is one of the most
entertaining shows on television it is
so insane
it is so i don't even know how it's
legal
to openly say to the
united states government i am coming
with the intention
of immigrating that is like exactly what
they say
do not do because it's illegal but
somehow tlc has figured it out
anyway in the trailer look what the [ __ ]
we found
i've lost all respect for myself
there's a fupa trooper here and season
six trailer
wearing [ __ ] h3 merch i can't wait to
see this
the season well i've got the chat i'm
gonna watch it all yeah here
let's watch the trailer i i kept reading
do you want more information about them
yeah tell me about matt lauer
so the feature was a perk for top
executives who wanted privacy
for personal calls or security
but it's not clear how many people had
it and apparently he was one of very few
if not the only one
that had one so
it's pretty weird story it did use it
according to the allegations he did use
it to lock women
in that is so he used it he did use it
he had it and he used it
allegedly damn
that's crazy man okay let's watch
i love that i mean a [ __ ] button that
locks the door of christ
sweet oh what do we got here the trailer
here we go tlc love tales everything tlc
makes is great the learning channel guys
it's gold
in 90 days we're going to be husband and
wife here we go
people say you know damn girl maybe she
could be
maybe maybe have you watched the season
maybe
the previous season i'm just a
dysfunctional broke
white guy with no prospects in life but
some beautiful girl from brazil is in
love with me
maybe she's using me there's five other
seasons of this yeah
maybe she's using me
maybe she just likes my personality yeah
right
no but the the american guys are always
like the most like
weird socially awkward
broke no professional prospects
basically the most undated
like very undateable in my opinion if i
was gay
versus what uh well you know
an eligible bachelor no but what is it
is it was really american and
yeah it's always an american i think
it's always an american guy or is it
no it's like there was there was one
really big girl no i mean i'm not gonna
say
that oh yeah yeah yeah that's not you
know
some people are into that not me no it
wasn't part of the story but she's a
huge girl
and there was like a super fit guy from
columbia yeah
and he kept trying to get her to go to
the gym so he was not into that
so she didn't want to yeah
it's great man it's [ __ ] amazing the
show is like drama city usa it's so good
i live on vacation lost my virginity
and had his baby wow that's a lot
she's beautiful she's sexy but she has
90 days
to get to know my mother you know you're
a virgin i live in the basement with my
eight-year-old mom she's beautiful she's
sick she's a supermodel
maybe she's using me
maybe she just wants to come live with
me and my mom in the basement
i work and also i work at uh i deliver
pizzas
not that they're i'm not degrading pizza
drivers but i'm just saying these guys
have no prospects
we get it ethan she's so eager to be in
love
she lets red flags just go if jesus came
down from heaven right now and said he
cheated on me
i wouldn't do anything about it i'm here
with your country
finally oh but there's
there's also hope and romance as well
the music is
tomorrow and i'm going to be right in
here every day
see that romantic [ __ ] i'm going to be
in your bed giving you the d
every
you're not gonna tell me not to touch my
son you're acting like a crazy
what what are you talking about what day
she's great
that's heaven baby i'm a catch
she walks into this guy's house which
like is full of garbage
and flies and [ __ ] welcome to heaven
baby
she might be using me
i'm concerned the life i have here isn't
enough for her can't you clean up before
internationally yep you can't even clean
up
this old coffee cup nope that's molding
she
does not need there's your boy
i've lost all respect i love this guy
we've got a sleeper cell
we've got a sleeper yeah we've got a
double agent
a ah if he's watching reach out
yeah give us the email dude god i love
it so much
him it's been hard and i'm struggling
are you doing this because you have this
baby he's i love that he's wearing the
shirt like every day apparently
wait is he one of the subjects or is he
like the brother okay i think it's his
sister
yes that is getting there god gotta got
it yeah
that [ __ ] is for his money period all
right well anyway oh my
jesus christ look at this guy
christ i'm not saying that
i mean that guy is not a catch i'm sorry
all right enough about this it could be
he might be he might be
he's going to give her the d all night
long the point is
that
it's generally one person is way out of
the other person's league
yeah and one person is way delusional
and one person has the opportunity to
give the other person way of the league
a visa
okay you guys get the [ __ ] idea um
oh yeah guys if you have any questions
or you want our opinion on something you
want to show us something you want me to
talk about something
email us i want to start answering
emails
every episode so email us at podcast
h3h3productions.com
what else we got um
[Music]
you have something i've got the fat
shaming fashion revolve
drop there's a company called revolve
which is a fashion company
that teamed up with lena dunham actually
i don't know what lena dunham
does is she comedian i just hear her
name all the time she's a writer
oh she's a writer um
at any rate she worked on a
collaboration with this
company and it's a female
empowerment um collab
so the idea behind it was that they
wanted to make clothes
that you know promoted body positivity
so with that in mind let me show you
what the final product was
um so here you go oh i can't i can't
expand it what the [ __ ]
um sometimes it dies away
this is definitely ian's fault
why is that i don't know so just zoom in
on the page yeah
usually when you click it it just pops
out that's bizarre let me try to refresh
it
well any oh man that's kind of annoying
just getting on the whole page
right try right clicking it and view
image
i'm not doing that so um
here's a beautiful skinny model that
says too bony to be boned
so the idea was that they took quotes
hurtful quotes and they used it as armor
to be like hey
your words don't hurt me so horrible
result
of modern feminism
[ __ ] feminist nightmare too bunny to be
boned
if you translated a bum onto her face
she'd have a better face
and of course here again being fat is
not beautiful it's an excuse
imagine that one is the worst i'm not a
skinny girl
imagine wearing that
so people can you imagine look at this
170 dollars
being fat is not beautiful it's an
excuse like what
should we fit yeah oh
so what they missed the mark so much
what happened here clearly i guess they
meant to have a heavier
size yeah you know
it's still a weird shirt if i'm being
honest it is but this combination the
clothes are small
right you cannot tell that it's a quote
yeah but either way the beautiful fit
model was really just uh
so people got so upset and everyone was
issuing apologies and
whatever whatever to me this image
really just is
what i love so much being fat is not
beautiful it's an excuse
170 bucks so thank you to lena dunham
and
um revolve for this collaboration
howie mandel
this is a really cringy one
howie mandel
[Applause]
tells tyra bank live on america's got
talent that she has fake hair
now i guess this is a somewhat common
thing of
of females i guess black females
a lot of them have fake hair weave
i watched a whole documentary yeah the
chris rock made called like
good hair or something it was really
interesting because i don't think he
made it
yeah i think it was chris rock and
i didn't actually know this was a thing
but a lot of black women have
fake hair like from india so their hair
they have like tiny little cornrows
and then they weave real hair
of like straight or wavy hair and they
have like really elaborate weaves
apparently you're not supposed to touch
black woman's hair
actually even a lot of white women have
extensions now
so extensions yeah no it's crazy like
yeah the extensions like i've seen it
where you take the extensions out and
there it's just like three times as much
volume
yeah it's like what the hell
i don't really personally care that much
about the whole hair thing but hey
women want to feel beautiful they want
to do their thing and god bless them
anyway howie apparently knows because
they spent a lot of time backstage
together
that tyra has fake hair and so that
probably is what makes this even more
embarrassing
so let us enjoy oh
heidi we i mean howie we miss the facial
hair so much
how does it feel with all that fake hair
on yourself i don't have no idea what
that feels like
fake hair that wasn't fake that was his
real hair oh i see what you did
you see what she did no she has fake
hair it was a joke never said that
wow it's so bad
he genuinely thinks that she's setting
him up for like a
a gag i don't know what was he thinking
or he's just really trying to make a
joke but it was so bad
well she said i have no idea what it
feels like to have fake hair
yeah and so he was like making a joke i
think
no but then i think he really was like
oh my god what did i say
you hear him in here watch he tries to
change the subject here it was a joke
never said that
no it's okay okay i wasn't talking about
what the heck is this going this is live
tv okay we're moving on i know
we have to move on isn't this disgusting
okay
tyron is not happy yeah
i mean it's i mean [ __ ]
i gotta watch that again i'm talking
about her head that was an awful save by
the way
no she has fake hair it was a joke never
said that
that that this was real when he's like
oh
[ __ ] right when real what do you mean
because he was like oh i shouldn't have
said that yeah
no it's okay i think he was trying to
make a joke but it was really
off the went wrong
so tyra has fake hair to be honest i
wouldn't have guessed it because
usually you can see it in the forehead i
don't know that's a really good weave i
guess
she's rich you know yeah she got that
crazy [ __ ] weebs you know
yeah you don't want it to be noticeable
sure but
it's pretty i mean so what the hell does
it look like when she takes her hair off
i don't know
you don't know about it i don't think
you take it off either when you
when you go to the barber you keep it on
all the time yeah and they fix it up
you guys should watch this documentary
good hair by chris rock it's really
interesting
um tara
howie fascinating stuff guys we've got
great content here on the h3 podcast and
you don't ever want to miss a single
episode because uh
you just don't know what's coming next
isn't that right either
yep we don't even know what's coming
next nobody knows
guys have you seen this um
joey salads this is kind of i don't know
this
i don't know when it's from but i love
this i don't think i've watched it with
you guys before but vitaly
saw joey salads at a gym and
like uh confronted him because joey said
that he wanted to [ __ ] his mom or
something
and it's just it's so priceless i gotta
tell you it's not recent because
vitali these days look like dragon ball
z
he does character oh man vitali looks
crazy these days
maybe we should show afterwards he looks
like bruno from ali g well anyway here
he is
what up guys so i just walked in the gym
and guess what i [ __ ] see
i see joey [ __ ] salads the [ __ ]
you know what natalie don't [ __ ]
don't don't put disrespect on joey
salad's name all right
joey salads he's a guy
you know what that's fine you're fine
he's the front of the show but
uh he's got a lot of dressing on that
salad
me disrespecting me my mother saying he
wants my mother
says he wants to [ __ ] my mother talking
all this smack
making videos online i walked into the
gym oh you just hit me
i think he's in the locker room why are
you sending me gay porn dan
just google battalion 2018 and that's
the first result
good what's up why are you gonna talk
all this [ __ ] what do you mean
all the videos you've made should
talking [ __ ] about my mom the one video
i made a year ago
yeah now i'll catch you fine i like
joey's boy band bull cup
i'm in front of you right now what
you're going to do about it it can't be
that old if he's got dongles
i was waiting for this moment to happen
all right well
no no no i met you in person you're
going to talk [ __ ] about my mom have you
ever spoken
anything bad about your mom no exactly
so why would you think if it's fun [ __ ]
your youtube
no it's not jokes i'm here in front of
you what you're gonna say about it
i gotta say it it's just stupid youtube
people in the video stupid yeah exactly
because you're gonna confront everybody
who has something bad to say about you
oh if i see him in person of course i
will of course i will hopefully run into
vitality
i'm in deep trouble the way he looks now
i'm not because yeah and your boy's not
going to help you
i'm serious i'll beat your [ __ ] ass
with my right hand while i'm filming my
left
it's not petty you [ __ ] disrespecting
my mother and you don't disrespect it
maybe in this country again not in
[ __ ] russia i apologize that i
disrespected your mother
i didn't mean it to be disrespectful
joey you said you want me
joey does tend to think that whatever he
does on youtube doesn't mean
anything yeah like a fake black lives
matter ah
yeah trump car experiment
he's missing i don't know oh my god look
at this picture of a tally let me pull
this up yeah that's
that's what he looks like today the
villain from
rocky or dragon ball z
he seriously looks like man
he looks like a suit like he's ivan
drogo that's the
that's the guy from rocky i mean he
looks like he's on his way to shoot a
gay porn and i mean i don't mean to say
it like this is a
like i mean he's got the bleach tips
he's got the pink top
there you into the muscles either i uh
actually
i'm not at all good thank god not to
this level i don't
what is that what's the good amount of
muscle for you well there's some in his
new vlog
you were pointing out to me today where
his bicep
is like big he's like driving his car
and a friend is recording from the side
and his
arm is like taking up the whole screen
like
what is that i just i get the feeling
like when dudes get this
jacked they do it for each other
i don't think that many women like
that's what i was trying to say about
women with all the surgeries
i feel like it becomes like a
competition between themselves and i
don't even think the guys even
care no i don't think so like of course
like a jack do with like a six-pack
is attractive and looks good and you
like that
but like at what point like here dan
just sent me this photo like
when you get like mr universe jacked i
feel like that's just
the dude i think there was nothing wrong
with him in the before picture
okay that's that's great you're
you're not you're an everyday man girl
um but at any rate i just i saw him he's
like working out with all of his dudes
and they're all getting like jacked as
[ __ ] and they're all like checking each
other out and they're all like almost
naked
i was like this is gay there's nothing
wrong with that but like this looks
like you know god bless some maybe he'll
find out
something new
that is interesting there's something
funny about that just a bunch of naked
dudes lifting he just made a boy a
boyfriend joke at joey right he was like
you and your boyfriend here
joey is that what he said i think joey
they might make a good couple though
i think they can make some really good
pranks together and
you know joey's no stranger to to gay
porn
he had a whole tumblr page for gay men i
don't know if you guys know that
he had this whole thing where he was
putting his dick in a hot dog bun
and putting like mustard on it and his
roommate was recording it and they
started putting it on tumblr
and they had a whole huge following oh
my god this is news to me he had a huge
whole following
of uh gay men following him yeah
and i think at one point he just got he
was like what am i doing are you racist
joey's the real variety man
yeah and i'll tell you and let me say
something about joey
when he was in here i shook his hand he
has the softest [ __ ] hand
i've ever smelled like lotion like bro i
touched his hand
and i was like what is your mouth
himself before he came so i don't know
you know yeah
you know do your thing joey
i'm sorry nothing wrong with that too
nothing want anyone to take if i was gay
i would suck so much dick
like who would you choose vitaly or joey
who would i [ __ ] wow that's a
[ __ ] that's a tough one dude well i know
vitelli can't even get it up
from the band box days joey seems like
he has a sweet soul if i'm being honest
vitaly seems totally unhinged and insane
yeah
joey he seems to have a sweet soul
and you know those soft hands would
would be
would have me here in a split second
so you're more of a personality i think
joey
yeah i think i'll go with joey all day
you joey if you're listening
[Laughter]
joey's gonna cut that part and upload it
to his channel
h3 wants to date joey's up yeah i want
to [ __ ] joey
i put your dick in a hot dog bun in a
damn split game second
um guys we have the best content here do
we not
what else goop you guys heard about oh
you know goop we always make fun of goop
when we do like quip reads
cause they say it's on oprah's league
it's in goop and i was like what the
[ __ ] is goop so
goop gwyneth paltrow the actress owns
this magazine called
goop and actually we've spoke about more
than a magazine
it's a it's a lifestyle brand it's a
multi-million
companies first of all i was like what
kind of name is goop apparently it's
just her initials gwyneth paltrow gp and
she's like i wanted a name that meant
everything and anything and nothing
i was like goop is a pretty literal
that's just like a sound of like
like a goop yeah it's like
it's gross it's like when you take a sh
when [ __ ] comes out of your ass goop
it's like that sound effect you keep
playing it's kind of a group
this is pretty goopy yeah that's just a
type of a group so anyway we spoke
briefly about goop before
because they got in trouble for selling
stickers that were apparently
infused with nasa technology
to increase your energy level and that's
the
total scheme what the [ __ ] but now
they're back they're being sued again
because they have vaginal eggs
uh jade eggs that you insert in your
vagina
this is fantastic stuff guys let me pull
up some pictures that are appropriate
for everyone you know
i've been more fascinated by this this
egg
um i don't want you to see this photo
because it's really graphic well here
let me show you this
so it's like an egg that you shove up
your vag and you keep it there like all
day
it's crazy what do you think about that
i mean what is that supposed to do
you here i'll read it i'll read i'll
tell you all about it it seems very
uncomfortable
um here i've got the whole
i got the lowdown here so
here there's a picture of basically it's
a drawing but i don't want to show it
but
you you you know it's it you know what
you put it up there
like a tampon i guess but except the
giant
stone
um from kegels to vaginal steaming we're
not shy here at goop
apparently not we apparently don't think
much either
we don't think much here at goop we're
not thinking oh i love this they call it
a strictly guarded secret of chinese
royalty
queens and concubines used them to stay
in shape for emperors
jade eggs were said to harness the power
of energy work and crystal healing
shiva rose has been working with them
for about seven years and
raves about the results jade eggs power
to cleanse and clear
make them ideal for spiritual detox
you still have any questions does that
explain everything
um jade eggs can help cultivate sexual
energy clear chi uh
yeah cultivate intensify and femininity
and
invigorate our life force just to name a
few
it's a holistic combination of things
where one benefits
builds to another jade also takes away
negative energy
it's a very heavy material and
incidentally
it just shoves really easily right up to
your [ __ ]
badge hole that's vulgar for them to
write
they did not anyway this shit's
hilarious
i'm bummed it's just for women man that
all sounds great you can try it bro
i got anal eggs i was about to say you
think it still works if you're going
another thing stopping you
yeah nothing's stopping you is right um
how do we start
when you first get your egg boil it what
it's a sacred space so make sure
you're clean for me it's about physical
cleaning you could put it under the
light of a full moon to cleanse or
recharge it
oh my god what the [ __ ]
or you could burn sage the egg does
absorb energy so
i like how they go from nasa energy to
chinese i don't know uh chinese secrets
you know what goop is it's the sound
that a jade egg makes when it plops out
of your veg
uh before i insert an egg i'll do a
ritual i'll place it on a beautiful
piece of fabric light a candle and then
shove it up my [ __ ] nasty snatch
for my ritual i'll imagine pure light
flowing from my nasty snatch
and shove an egg in there it really
explains who is this that supposedly
likes
explaining it's this is something
herself no
no it's some some lady one of their
editors i would assume
always wrap the egg and silk keep it
clean and store it on an
altar i don't know what it should take a
sacred place in your life an altar
what is that it's like a sacred podium
i don't know can an egg get stuck or
lost
good question i don't uh good question
this is the most common question we get
and no it cannot get lost
depending on the size of your
cavanaugh's cavernous giant
vag possibly it could get lost for a
couple of weeks depending on
on how fat your vagina is no they say um
no it cannot get lost what about stuck
but there are ones that have a toll
drilled in them
so that you can bungee in and splunk in
your vagina and
follow the lifeline to the egg
now you can put a thread through the egg
and
to make it easy to take out like way if
you were to spelunk into a cavern
do you know what splunking is it's cave
diving i
yeah i remembered that from the prank
invasion
spell honking right are there people who
should not use jade eggs very good
question
if you're on your cycle do not use
people if you're pregnant
do not shove that egg in there okay
oh man if you have a functioning brain
do not shove it in i yeah exactly people
with functioning braids should not use
jade eggs so there it is
so what happened is that uh so what
happened was that they're being sued for
basically
making unsubstantiated unscientific
untested claims basically everything i
just read people like less [ __ ]
you cannot say that and they came into a
and they're being sued for settlement oh
they did so yeah
why are you so familiar because they
paid
150 oh they lost 145 000 so there you go
i'm more i'm just more interested in the
egg itself that product is incredible
how much is it it's like 70 yeah 70
bucks
not bad for a
not bad for a uh rock that you shove up
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not just any rock
i got a couple of rocks if you guys want
for 60 bucks you can shove up your ass
are they jade are they recharged by the
energy of the moon
yes oh [ __ ] that then i'm in there's
another headline
fortnite has been cited in more than 200
divorce proceedings
that's it there's really nothing more
than that and finally guys we do have an
email
if you guys have emails questions
concerns you want to hear us talk about
something make sure to
email podcast at h3hdproductions.com
i have got an email to close up the show
today from a sweet young man
named daniel now daniel
like many of you out there are young men
impressionable minds who are looking for
answers and better ways to live a more
holistic uh
natural life and he heard our discussion
mine and um births about
wiping how we wipe from the front we
march
to the beat of our own wipe we
mar we march from the front others they
wipe from the back
the normal not well normal is the
subjective term
and i want to go that far say a normal i
mean
it's a standard posi body positivity
so i'm going to read this email i
thought it was a great email and i
wanted to share it with all you guys and
and it really and it created a new
dimension on this whole conversation
about front wiping versus
back wiping okay something that i had
which was an unintended consequence but
a wonderful consequence of it
so um let me begin here
dear ethan
for 25 years i have been a back wiping
neanderthal
today i am proud to say that i have
thrown in the toilet paper
and have committed to front wiping
moving forward
i was first introduced to front wiping
in high school when a participant on a
reality show
revealed to his peers that he wiped from
the front
i like the other people on the show was
disgusted by the thought of it
it garnered the typical reaction that
most unenlightened people
have where they imagine smearing feces
up their ball sack
out of my own curiosity i tried it one
day and confirmed my own suspicion that
it was an
insufficient way of cleaning my ass and
due to my
naivety however
oh due to my own naivety however i now
realize i was doing it incorrectly
by converting my own stand up back
wiping technique to a front
style that was wildly uncomfortable
fast forward to 10 years later and a big
fan of your show
i was disappointed to be faced with the
issue once again
you spoke with tom segura and crystalia
i found myself disagreeing with you
as i had already settled this debate
myself
as a teenager it was not until your
episode with burke chrysler that i was
willing to give front wiping a second
chance when i learned that you remained
seated
through the experience i realized i had
made a mistake in my past experience
then something that either you or bert
said really clicked with me
it does not make sense to wipe a hole it
needs to be a
scoop in order to clean and i do believe
that wasn't either so
gross after this i was ready
to be like please we're talking about
scooping
this is personal and spiritual
after this i was ready to truly open
myself to change in my wiping technique
while it felt a bit weird at first i
have been blown
away by the results first off it is more
a natural reach
as opposed to the awkward and standing
up and reaching backwards you don't need
to stand up
i stay seated a lot of people stand up
you guys back there do you stand up when
you wipe from the back
uh it's more of like a slight lift and
you left
i mean you left it's not a full stance i
mean it's it's still technically seated
i'd say
somewhere in between it's a lift
this is emotional okay this is important
to me
first off it is more natural reach as
opposed to the awkward stand up and
reaching backwards
secondly i'm able to perform a quick
couple of
scoops it's what he wrote and it's what
i said god damn it this is the truth
as opposed to a rough wipe that only
makes the task harder as you smear [ __ ]
up your ass crap and lastly i'm able to
finish
in less wipes with a cleaner result i
just wanted to thank you for your
continued efforts
you are truly the nelson nelson mandela
of wiping
and i feel as if i am not the only
person to be converted by your wisdom
i had doubts about this technique for a
decade and
i can only think about all the wasted
time i've spent using an
insufficient inefficient wiping motion
i recommend all back wipers give it one
week trial
because the result is truly life
changing
thank you you're sincerely daniel p.s
i do not use baby wipes i've heard
nothing but horror stories about the
damn
okay no yeah i you had me until you
started talking [ __ ] on baby wipes
daniel
but you know i think it's really
wonderful i think i was removed because
i was never my intention to convert
anyone i never thought it would be
myself
as a un misunderstood soul a victim of
my own success
of wiping but i hope that it doesn't
switch back once he understands that he
doesn't need to stand up
to wipe from the back dude's been wiping
his ass his whole life he knows what
he's doing
um interestingly zach i just heard
our sound guy he's our sound intern he's
helping us out with sound
um he told me today that he in his house
they don't even have toilet paper
they go pure wet wipe which i've never
seen
i've never seen that and frankly i find
it a little strange because i would
never i would never recommend to start
wet
because that's just asking for trouble
i recommend to zach and to all anyone
else out there you have to take a hybrid
approach because you want to start
try and what so zach welcome aboard
pretty strange zach do you wipe from the
front or the back can you talk into the
mic
method you serious whoa at first i was
doing before but
i tried it out and i happen to really
like it wait are you [ __ ] kidding me
you're a connor
if he's just saying that you want me to
bend over
yeah i don't know what that would prove
to us
wait let me get this straight sack are
you just saying this to get the job
right here or something he wouldn't lie
about this
you swear he wouldn't lie about this
hela it's embarrassing
it is very embarrassing but baby wipes
let me tell you
save your life hold on hold hold on
back up hang on you're telling me that
you wiped from the back
until you heard this show and then based
on my anecdote
you decided to lift your own balls and
dick in one hand
reach under them and scoop out the [ __ ]
from the front
100 i cannot believe it and you prefer
it
i do prefer it yes dude
that's incredible
wait and ian is the front one i don't
know that we've ever asked him where
where do you wipe from here i think we
did
i'm from the front seat yeah and then
and then you're a back wiper
hold on right yeah wait dan is the odd
man out here for
yeah and ian have you always wiped from
the front
no i converted probably in high school
you kidding oh
what made you convert what makes you say
to yourself
in the middle of your life that you're
going to start lifting up your dick and
balls and scooping out [ __ ] from
underneath it
i didn't know that that was possible and
then i think someone in a show
said it and i went what that's madness
but i tried it and it never went back
and you think it's superior
absolutely dude telling you
listen to me i am truly a prophet i've
been saying
dan have you tried it now you know what
i did yes
no i gave it i gave it an honest go did
you scoop though
there was some scooping yeah i mean no i
i i
i wanted to be objective you know i i
tried to go into it without bias didn't
like it didn't like it now dan tell me
you were sitting on the john
mm-hmm right and generally where i did
my business yeah but i just want to make
sure you did the technique right and
then
what which hand did you wipe with oh
well i'm a righty so
you lifted your balls and dick with your
left hand correct you remained seated
uh yes then you went in with the right
hand went in
under underhanded underhand technique
yeah that's how you do it
no i i think i nailed it i think i
nailed the technique and i'm just i'm
not a fan
you may need to try the the group
they can make an egg in there i'm down
for that for sure
you need to open your chakras well i
have to tell you
this was an eye-opening not only was
zach a recent convert
yeah but that ian independent and in
he's a talented young man he's until
he's got a good head on his shoulders
in high school he said to himself
there's got to be a better way
and he was converted from that first
scoop and i find that power i can't
believe that we just found out two
conversions in one week
wow who says that we don't do amazing
work here important
incredible stuff
and i thought that we were just talking
here wasting everyone's time
no evil how many people are gonna front
scoop tonight
let us know send us some emails send us
your thoughts podcast
hch3productions.com all right well uh
today
is friday we've got oh ksi on tuesday
hey that'll be exciting yeah we've got a
lot to talk i don't think we've
announced that
yet no we didn't so ksi's on tuesday
that's our episode next week
i'm working on an h3 video hopefully
we'll be out this weekend i don't know
who knows
we'll see i'll do my best with that all
being said
how'd we do today do i think we did
solid
how were the numbers a lot of chuckles
back here i think
the numbers are low because i heard
people say
it wasn't showing up yeah i apologize to
anybody that didn't get the notification
i mean
why is that i got it on my phone um but
yeah i guess in the tweet
i saw some responses that people uh were
having trouble finding the episode today
so yeah we will we will investigate
maybe email the our our contacts at um
even when i went to our podcast channel
you know it will usually show there it
didn't show i had to click on the videos
yeah what what the hell
youtube well enough people found it
because we're at like 17 000 now
yeah ultimately it did well but um but
yeah anybody that uh
that got screwed by that we apologize i
find that strange
i wonder if there's a thing in the
settings we [ __ ] up or
not like probably just a youtube bug i
think it's got to be because again i i
did get it
i mean i i got all the notifications dan
we have a contact we can email at
youtube right yeah yeah we'll we'll
reach out we'll see if we can figure out
what happened
oh man you gotta love youtube it's like
never know what you're gonna get
imagine being like nbc and you're like
new episode of seinfeld
maybe half of the people's tvs don't
turn on
half of everybody just gets scrambled
waves when they turn on nbc
imagine that
alright guys have a great weekend
asmr all the best ksi on tuesday
and uh that'll be it for this week okay
guys
all right all right is this it is friday
right it's friday
but what do we have to do schedule was
so mixed up lately i don't know the week
friday tomorrow we've got
dinner yeah we're gonna go
sunday we've got dinner it's your dad's
birthday
oh yeah my dad's birthday we're gonna
take him out
day yeah we've got [ __ ] to do
i hate having stuff to do on the weekend
you know
sucks
[Applause]
you feel free to end it anytime all
right bye everybody we're going
out thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you